What did you learn about risk at a whorehouse?
It's a very risky job, especially if you're
working the illegal market
there's always a risk that your client could
be the police
or just a deranged lunatic who will kill you.
Allison Schrager is the author of An Economist
Walk Into A Brothel
a fascinating dive into how different communities
assess risk and what we can learn from that
including sex workers at the Moonlite Bunny
Ranch in Nevada.
I went to the brothel to see how the legal
market manages risk
'cause the legal market provides a fairly
risk free space to do sex work
where the women have security, where they
don't have to worry about screening their clients
and they go through thorough background checks
and disease screenings
and have a lot of support.
Their risk is minimized and then also the
risk for the johns is also minimized?
Exactly and that's sort of an interesting
play on pimp I guess
Dennis Hof when he was alive loved sort of
reclaiming the expression pimp.
Because when I think of a pimp I think of
this guy
who's pushing these women into these very dangerous
situations and then taking all the money.
So we call that in finance an unsensible risk,
you generally, in finance people who take
more risk are supposed to get more reward
and you know a market isn't functioning properly
when the people who take the biggest risks
don't get the biggest reward
which happens often in crime because they're
sort of messed up markets for a lot of reasons.
So what's interesting about what Dennis does
is he actually makes his spread, you know,
what the johns pay and what the women have
to pay
to minimize risk or reduce risk for everyone
involved in the transaction.
He is sort of a pioneer in the world of sex
work.
He was running some sort of business with
time shares
and just had a lot of friends in the porn
industry and spent time in brothels
and had this idea that you could approach
sex work the way you approach time shares.
It's like a total ripoff is what you're saying.
I think it's a fair transaction, you know,
you're not locked in like you are with a time share
you're not stuck seeing these sex workers
year after year
and it's not like you then have to sell your
time with them somewhere else.
But the idea is that you are effectively renting
someone,
renting a service I guess is a nicer way to
think about it.
Nevada has a long history with legal sex work.
Before, you know, they were kinda dingy sort
of depressing places.
They're not like luxury spas, the women there
were, you know,
having to be there for hours or days at a
time where they weren't allowed to leave.
There were set prices, they had to, no control
over who they were servicing.
So this idea that he was going to make them
all independent businesswomen
and that they would negotiate every transaction
on their own terms
only have sex with people they wanted to and
set the prices themselves.
To meet with the world's most interesting
risk takers,
Schrager traveled the country to study horse
breeders, military commanders,
professional poker players and Hollywood paparazzi.
On Hawaii's north shore she found herself
attending the
Annual Big Wave Risk Assessment Safety S ummit
where she found that surfers and financial
risk advisers have a lot in common.
Their leader is this guy named Brian Keaulana
who had this idea that risk is something that
could be managed
which is the whole ethos of financial economics.
So he had the same idea and he's been studying
risk science with the military
and had this idea that they would regularly
have these summits
where they would discuss risk science but
for big wave surfers.
And they really discuss a lot of the same
things we do in pension conferences.
Different ways you can minimize risk, manage
risk, take risks in smarter ways.
For instance waves travel in sets, so you'll,
like big waves will run in a pack of five.
In finance we'd call this a hedge, which is
taking less risk but still getting some reward
sort of calibrating it just so, so you never
want to take an early wave in a set,
because if you wipe out there'll be four or
five large waves barreling on you
so what you want to do is take a wave in the
fourth or fifth set,
in a way that might be a smaller wave,
just so you have less risks.
They talk about things like that.
These guys are not necessarily adrenaline
junkies, they, what they do is risky
but they're not big risk takers.
No in fact there's almost something very intellectual
about the way they take risk
it's, you know I was talking to Greg Long
who's a very well known big wave surfer
about how it's almost this intellectual endeavor
of here's this huge force of matter
how can I do this in a very intellectual way
and minimize the risk
and still be able to do this activity.
The markets that are working well in your
book are kind of,
they're free and open where a lot of different
participants, you know, kind of work through things
and certain norms that kind of inscribe.
On the one hand that means when people from
outside and industry come in and say
you guys are doing it all wrong
I'm going to bring my, you know, my outsider
knowledge to bear on this.
They don't typically work very well, or it
doesn't last very long
but then also regulators often come in and
figure they can tame a market.
Is there something going on there about risk
that regulators and kind of neophytes both
dismiss?
Yeah for sure and I mean I did that too.
Because I would go into these markets, I don't
have any expertise in surfing or horse breeding
and I would always come in with
'well this is how we do it in finance and
have you thought about doing options on studs?'
and everyone's always like
'no of course not, this is not how it works.'
and of course they were always right.
But the regulation's hard because every community
has this very strong libertarian streak.
Like the big discussion at the big wave surf
conference was systemic risk
so systemic risk is that you take your big
institution, you take a big risk,
and you bring down the whole system.
So this is the big debate in big wave surfing
as they, you know,
as technology be itll jet skis or inflatable vests,
encourage people to take on more risk
and that diverts rescue resources to other
people
or you have water crashing into other people
or, you know, it's a safety risk for people
to have to rescue them.
So it's in a sense a systemic risk.
And so they're constantly debating who should
be able to buy safety equipment
and who should be surfing big waves.
And I was like 'well you know we have these
discussions at pension conferences
and it sounds like you're asking for some
level of regulation.'
You know, how, should you be like, should
you be licensed to be a big wave surfer?
Like the same way you're licensed to be a
scuba diver.
And this as I said like, they're all pretty
liberal about most things.
They're like 'oh the big wave vest, the inflatable
vest company that sells vests to anyone'
which they find very offensive because it
means more risk for everyone
'they're just about the money.'
But once I was like 'well do you think you
should be regulated
do you think that big wave surfing should
be licensed?'
They're like 'no, no we need to keep the government
out of big wave surfing.'
They were very emphatic about that.
What is the big takeaway that you,
because the book is also on a certain level
is a self help book
or you know a personal finance book, let me
put it that way.
Yeah personal finance gets a bad rap, you
know, especially in academic finance.
But I think it's a bigger message than just
personal finance
which is that people should feel comfortable
taking more risks.
We don't really give people the tools to feel
comfortable with risk taking.
But you really do need to take risks to make
your life move forward.
In any aspect of your life, if it's your relationship,
if it's your job, anything
is to help people understand that there is
a way of taking risk
where they can do stuff to protect themselves
if things go wrong,
there aren't any guarantees,
but they can definitely increase the odds
things will work out for them.